Dave chappelle.
Dave's my God brother.
So I'm a bit biased and we came of age
together in New York City,
being in college and him at the Boston
Comedy Club,
which is a college of sorts for him.
Um,
I was actually known to some as Dave's
Puerto Rican bodyguard because,
uh,
they didn't,
they didn't know exactly what to make
of,
of the,
of the guy who didn't smile much and
just sat in the back of the club club
reading books.
Uh,
they didn't realize that that was at
Columbia University.
And the only way I can have the
privilege hanging out the comedy club as
if I actually read books while somebody
else was telling jokes.
So say,
yeah,
Dave.
Dave's definitely my favorite comic.
Okay.